wer sich derzeit harry potter bei amazon
aufs nachttischchen holen möchte wird
enttäuscht
neun tage warten
kaum eine option der hintergrund amazon
fordert von buchverlagen 50 prozent
rabatt auf ebooks statt den bisher
üblichen 30 prozent
wenn verlage sich dagegen wehren hält
amazon ihre gedruckten titel bewusst
nicht an lager und liefert sich
verzögert aus bücher werden als geiseln
genommen so der treffende vergleich in
einem blog der literaturagent peter
fritz vertritt autoren gegenüber
verlagen amazon spiele derzeit seine
marktmacht hemmungslos aus sagt er sind
drastische methode sind gern ihre verlag
warum und mit ebooks prinz noch nicht
gross boykottieren das ist technisch
schwierig und in trance also versuche es
ist einfach der zum verlag vielleicht
gerät wird mit dem hören
amazon chef jeff bezos argumentiert
stets mit tieferen preisen und dem
nutzen für die kunden
der branchenführer bei den
elektronischen büchern will in den usa
schon bald eine flatrate lancieren also
ein unlimitiertes bücher aber für nicht
einmal zehn dollar im monat
jedes mittel scheint recht um der
konkurrenz margen und marktanteile
abzujagen was bei sus in einem seiner
seltenen interviews jedoch verneint
jammern ist keine strategie nicht amazon
bricht über den buchmarkt herein sondern
die zukunft die verdrängung der
tante-emma-läden ist im buchhandel schon
länger tatsache amazon ist zwar
vorreiter
doch die anderen machen mit jetzt spüren
auch die verlage den druck besorgt
verfolgt sabine dahlemann das
geschäftsgebaren des giganten der
zürcher dörlemann verlag ein kleiner
fisch zwar hat mit jens steiner aber den
aktuellen schweizer buchpreisträger im
programm
amazon hier kein sympathieträger
es ist ein handelspartner
wenn auch ein etwas ungeliebter
buchhandel verdrängt der eigentlich für
uns sehr wichtig ist wenn es ihn nicht
gäbe das wunderbar aber die zeiten
können uns leider nicht zurück wünschen
einmal so ein lied believe weil das weiß
ich eigentlich wäre es für uns nicht
möglich also wir haben als verlag
natürlich die aufgabe unsere küche
überall bzw
die bücher unserer autoren überall die
fahrbahn zu halten und es würde eben
halt doch ein teil der verkäufe
wegbrechen von daher kommt das für uns
eigentlich gar nicht in frage
diogenes die nummer eins in der schweiz
hat vor zehn jahren bereits amazon die
stirn geboten
opa frankreich darüber wird geschwiegen
60 prozent seiner e books verkauft
jürgen es über amazon ist der verlag
auch jetzt wieder unter rabatt rupp
nein sie mir bis jetzt mit dass er hoffe
dass die betroffenen verlag daher
blieben und krampf so lange so gut sich
und will wenn wenn da wenn verlag da
verliere dann werden wir über kurz oder
lang auch mit dem konfrontiert sie
widerstand ist also doch nicht ganz
zwecklos was verlage auch gern sehen
sind die kleber von bekennenden amazon
boykotteuren in den usa unterstützt von
bestseller-autor tv star stephen colbert
auch er hat ein buch geschrieben das als
kreisel dient jetzt zückt er in seiner
show die waffe moment hallo um amazon
kunden denen dies gefiel kauft noch das
aber so unersättlich immer kleinere
margen für autoren und verlage
was folgt morgen an sollen die atome
fünf lecker und preis festsetzen und
eigentlich der verlag verstehen mittels
mal was stört ausschließen
noch ist amazon aber weit davon entfernt
denn das wichtigste was ein verlag
leisten aufbauarbeit und autoren pflege
kriegt auch die perfekte vertriebs
maschine nicht hin